[Music]
thank you
it's raining men in Miley Cyrus's music
video for her song River sometimes we
just need a dance floor Banger AKA they
don't want me to talk about how the fact
the song is about
it's nasty the singer rocks a black mini
dress and stilettos while she dances
with shirtless models all around her
oh yeah
[Applause]
so what's the meaning behind the song
well following her breakup Anthem
flowers which is seemingly about her
ex-husband Liam
hemsworths
[Music]
Miley explains river is about her past
experience with love another track that
could be about the Australian actor it
was a time in my life where
I was going through just a lot
emotionally and personally and I guess
all my songs kind of evolved they could
start as something that was a trouble
like it just feels like it's an April
Shower it never stops raining and then
it started raining down like love yeah
and that love is thanks to Miley's
latest romance she's currently dating
musician Max mirando that's a couple
making a rare appearance together
arriving at the launch party for Miley's
eighth studio album Endless Summer
Vacation Miley sporting a similar dress
to the one in the river visual along
with a green fur coat
we'll see if River follows the success
of flowers the track spent six weeks at
number one on the Billboard Hot 100 and
it's the fastest song in history to hit
500 million streams on Spotify it never
goes exactly how I think it's going to
but somehow it always ends up being
better and if you want more or Miley
specifically some live performances
you're in luck
the Grammy winner returns to her Disney
roots for a concert special Endless
Summer Vacation backyard sessions which
is streaming now on Disney Plus
foreign